here
peter ferrara
is the author this is book tv on c-span
2.
my name is sarah belleen i'm the events
director here at kramer books and it's
really my pleasure to welcome you and to
welcome randy tonight for his book blood
brothers
randy is a distinguished professor of
history at purdue university he's
written biographies of iconic athletes
and celebrities he specializes in us
history u.s sports history and the
history of popular culture which clearly
combine
in this new book
the blood brothers the fatal friendship
between muhammad ali and malcolm x is
really the first book uh to offer an
in-depth portrait of their complex
friendship and it um
really uh goes deep and uses previously
untapped resources uh from fbi records
to personal documents and so we're so uh
so pleased to have randy here today
and we're really glad that randy is
joined tonight by kojo nandi
kojo is the host of the kokonami show a
live talk show produced by wamu 88.5
then arizona weekends at noon weekdays
at noon excuse me on fridays at noon uh
kojo hosts the politics hour on wnu
working as a journalist in the district
since the 70s at multiple media multiple
media outlets kojo has been dubbed quote
the washingtonian of the year by
washingtonian magazine and it has been
listed among the district's most
influential people by the pub by that
publication washingtonian and by deceist
we're so glad that kojo could join us
tonight this is one of our many partner
events with wnu 88.5 our local npr
station
we are so pleased to partner with wamu
they
share so many of our values of bringing
community together
having great discussions and having
great conversations and asking wonderful
questions so we're so glad that wmu can
be here in our community and here
tonight in the bookstore thank you again
so much for coming everybody please join
me in welcoming randy roberts and cody
navdy to him
thank you so very much sarah and thank
you all for showing up on what's clearly
a dark and stormy night
if you've been to bermuda you know
that's a drink also you can get a dark
and stormy tonight would be a good night
for dark and stormy before we get
started with tonight's events i'd just
like not only to thank sarah and the
whole staff here
at kramer books but the wamu team is
working with the team here on events
because well we know that listeners are
also readers
and tonight we're here as you heard to
talk with randy roberts about blood
brothers he and i will get the
conversation rolling
and move to a question and answer
session with you after we have talked
for a little while but first
randy roberts welcome
thank you very much
happy to be here and i am happy to be
here with you
first what got you started
on looking at this you have written
about sports stars and sports legends
before
but this as far as i can see is the
first time
you looked at this combustible mix
of sports and politics
in a
relationship well i have looked at
relationships before
i had well
i i did i did a book earlier on uh joe
namath and bear bryant so i i looked at
a relationship
i started with the idea that i wanted to
write a book about
muhammad ali and i was writing the book
this book was co-written with johnny
smith so i want to give him full credit
uh for co-writing the book
because quite frankly muhammad ali
was my champion okay
if you're if you if you like boxing if
you followed boxing people that lived
through the 1930s and the early 1940s
joe lewis was their champion and in the
1950s rocky morrisiano was in their
champion or in the 1920s it was jack
dempsey well if you live
through the 1960s
and the 1970s muhammad ali was your
champion in the ring he was your
champion and what is even rarer
outside of the ring he was
my champion and so i thought wow
i'd like to write a book about that
and johnny and i started to work on it
and the more we worked on it the more we
decided you know
what's really interesting is how
cassius marcellus clay
became muhammad ali what went into that
and the more we looked at it the more we
realized it was it was malcolm x the
cassius clay was almost inhabiting the
mind of malcolm x and we decided you
know that's an interesting story it's
it's a short period of time
we can look at it fully and and deal
with all the sources that we could dig
up on it and and it's a it's it's a
moment that
helps change american history i think
from that period in the first half of
the 1960s the three great black leaders
martin luther king
malcolm x and
improbably
cassius marcellus clay
who later became muhammad ali right i
was a teenager growing up in guyana
south america
and we sent boxers to the olympics in
rome in 1960
one of the boxers we sent there
even though he got knocked out in the
first round of his fight
somehow he managed to get a photograph
of himself
and the eventual winner of the light
heavyweight division
at those olympics the winner in that
division
at that olympics was who
it was cassius marcellus clay and
and quite frankly it wouldn't be hard to
get your picture with cassius clay he
met everybody he was every place in the
olympics there was a one article we we
read that i i remember reading and one
of the things that the athletes in the
games did is they exchanged pins
and the new york times said the official
winner of exchanging pins in the
olympics was cassius marcellus clay uh
you know for an athlete to expend an
enormous amount of energy
running around the olympic village
running around rome meeting everybody
accepting every interview uh it probably
wasn't a good thing to do other than
he won the gold medal so he couldn't do
any better than that but when we looked
at the photograph what we saw was this
unbelievably handsome young man
and as you said he accomplished all of
this at the olympics and he had what for
us was the unusual name of cassius
marcellus clay we discovered that his
brother was named rudolph valentino clay
and so it all started in a way with
their father what we did not understand
at the time
was that they had not led
the lives that cassius's appearance
would have led you to believe that they
led
they had a much rougher upbringing and
the consciousness about the relationship
between black and white people started
with his father talk about that
no question about it and that is his
father by the same name cassius
marcellus clay
um
was a sign painter
and an artist you can still go to black
churches in louisville and you can see
signs of his work he believed that he
was a great artist okay he also believed
he was a great singer and he would break
out in a song i've listened to
interviews uh that are
in in archive collections and interviews
of of the father and he would break into
a song and he would talk about how good
of a singer he was and what a great
artist he was and he was destined in his
own mind to be
famous he was michelangelo
frank sinatra though he said frank
sinatra was a pathetic singer
i can't go along with that dean martin
gave high remarks to but anyway uh he
thought he was going to be but he was
kept down his career was stunned because
he was black and it was a theme he
talked about with his with his sons all
the time not sometimes but all the time
oppression of whites he grew up the cash
both of them in a segregated section of
louisville
and in in cassius learned early
that you stayed away from white people
okay that you
enter if you interact with white people
it can do you no good harm's going to
come from it the one thing i interviewed
one person from louisville who was a
friend of cassius when cassius was
younger and he said he talked about the
lessons that they learned what their
parents told him don't go here don't go
here don't do this don't do that
number one
don't get arrested because if you go to
jail we can't protect you there's
nothing we can do it you know danger
will come
i think about that i mean we're living
through
and
what seems to be an unprecedented plague
of of black
kids being murdered uh murders too
strong but being shot by policemen and
maybe there was some truth to it that's
what his parents were warning him
against but it also helps to explain
why despite the fact that he was able to
charm everyone around him why despite
the fact that
he was doing so very well as a boxer
he became attracted to the nation of
islam he started going to nation of
islam meetings why how come
well remember
let's look at
he was born in 1942 okay
he was about the same age as emmett till
he remembered
the the murder of emmett till his father
talked about emmett till all the time
who was down in money mississippi i
think and was uh taken by uh several
white men for supposedly wolf whistling
uh a white woman probably didn't emmett
till had a stuttering problem i don't
know if you know the story of emma tell
but
he had trouble saying certain letters
and
he's a kind of whistle because it would
put his mouth in a position where he
wouldn't stutter
maybe that was what happened but anyway
for whatever he did he ends up dead and
and
muhammad heard this over and over also
in muhammad's neighborhood there was a
family that moved just a few blocks away
into a black neighborhood and their
house was firebomb so he felt
you know um he was interested he wasn't
interested in integration okay he wasn't
part of the
advancement
national association advancement he was
he wanted
he believed in in in separation of races
and so obviously the nation of islam
appealed to him
he's and his brother rudolph started
going in the back door
at meetings of the nation of islam when
he was in locations where
he had
a fight or some other event he was
obviously attracted to the nation and
ultimately he would meet malcolm x and
be attracted to malcolm x and malcolm x
would also
be um very very interested
in who was then
cassius clay
but as things have evolved in popular
culture they were during a time
when as you know there was a dispute
between malcolm and dr martin luther
king about what the best way forward was
but when we look at popular culture
today or when i look at popular culture
today
here's what i noticed
there was a movie
uh a popular feature film made about
malcolm x
there was a popular feature film
made about
ali
and it wasn't until the last two years
that there was a feature film that was
made not about dr king but about his
role in selma what has emerged from that
ear
is that the most charismatic figures of
that era turned out to be
malcolm x
and muhammad ali who now capture the
popular imagination why do you think
that was charisma
partly charisma though
my goodness i mean martin luther king
had charisma his
as a his speaking ability was
non-peril
um
i think
malcolm
and cassius muhammad ali had a harder
edge to him
you know they they weren't compliant
they they were tougher they were
stronger you know they
they they didn't preach turning the
other cheek okay as malcolm once said
you know
you shoot my dog you better watch out
for your cat okay you know he was going
to cut he was going to come aft
it wasn't it was going to be an eye for
an eye and a boxer has that same sort of
defiance so maybe it's that
well it also seemed to me that it was in
part because of their relationship and
in part
because both of them at one period were
hated
people forget
that there was a time when
both malcolm x
and muhammad ali were hated because of
their relationship with the nation of
islam i hear you're absolutely right on
that
you know i'm dealing with a time where
muhammad ali
was probably the most hated athlete in
american history now
that will change his stand on the on the
vietnam war ameri he never changes
america will change and and but at the
time i'm dealing with he is absolutely
hated and of course
malcolm x
was the most hated
black leader the most hated politician
in america i mean this is a person when
the president of the united states was
assassinated only about a week later
malcolm x said well as far as he was
concerned it was chickens coming home to
roost that america's violence was being
revisited upon america
so
cassius clay gets interested in the
nation of islam
malcolm x is the minister in the mosque
in new york
how do the two meet
cassius went to train
in miami
and when he was in miami he started to
attend
some nation meetings and he met a person
who became kind of a tudor forum in
miami a man by the name of captain sam
saxton
and captain sam told him the theology of
the nation of islam and the leaders and
they talked about different aspects of
the nation but one time when cassius was
back home
in louisville he got a call from captain
sam captain sam this was in june of
1962. captain said um there's going to
be a rally a nation of islam rally in
detroit
and
why don't you come i'll come pick you up
we'll drive up to detroit and you can
meet malcolm x and malcolm was the
spokesman for the nation of islam he was
by far the most famous figure in the
nation of islam and cassius said that's
fine so they went to a luncheonette
before the rally
and there
[Music]
sort of shaped like this
but sitting in the back at a table
facing the door where he always sat
back facing the door was malcolm x
and cassius goes up and says hello my
name's cassius clay
smiles
god was he handsome
and malcolm sees this dignified strong
powerful man
but he has no idea who cassius clay is
you know he's never heard of cassius
clay he doesn't follow boxing he just
sees a very impressive very cur
seemingly charismatic man but he picked
up boxing he learned it
the nation of islam at that point
did not allow its members to participate
in what they call sport and play
so
why was it
that despite the fact that this guy had
a profession in sport and play as a
boxer
did malcolm x see something there that
he thought needed to be developed that's
an excellent question
by that time
malcolm and elijah muhammad who was the
head of the nation of islam
were starting to split apart there was a
power struggle who's going to succeed
elijah muhammad elijah muhammad was
older his health was bad he had been in
chicago but he was living mostly in
phoenix at this time and there's a a
sense that maybe malcolm was too
powerful so there was a division taking
place and and malcolm was beginning to
chaff
under the constraints of the nation of
islam you know he wasn't he wasn't
allowed to do malcolm wanted to become
more active in the struggle and elijah
muhammad said no you stay away from it
okay
we we do not say we do not deal with
with members of the naacp
we
you stay away from king we're our own
separatist organization and this wasn't
enough for malcolm
and so i think in the back of his mind
the germ was
taking
shape that he was going to start his own
organization someday and he could see
the charisma
of this person you know uh you know that
that that athletes have
could have a potential
political use
he had charisma he talked all the time
he never seemed to listen
but he listened very closely to malcolm
why was this
outgoing
talkative person
the real cassius clan
that's several questions there let me
first say
who knows who the real captain was
this is a person
that uh
that was
he was the most wonderful mimic
possible he could inhabit another person
so one person said of cash's play in
fact i've heard this from several
persons if he's if you said something he
liked the next day he would say it and
the third day he would say it better
than you said it and he would think it
was his okay i mean
and he could become whoever he wanted to
become you know there's a
there's a
a poem that i like
the love song of jail for proof rock and
i bet you have a copy of elliot
but in that
there's this one
line where uh the poet
is he's going towards an assignation
he's talking about there will be time
there will be time time to prepare the
face the to meet the faces that you meet
okay the idea is
who is he
maybe we're a bunch of different people
i mean
you know we're one person with friends
we're another person with colleagues
we're another person with you know
worse succession well this is the way
cassius was
in the roman olympics for example
he was a representative of america an
offender of america when a russian
reporter asked him about racism in
america he said oh don't don't worry
about that
we've got we've got important people
taking care of that okay it may be hard
for me to get a dinner sometimes in the
district of columbia he didn't say the
district of columbia but he could have
said the district of columbia but but
it's getting taken care of and america
is still the best country ever
including yours russian
uh
okay that's one face then
he turns professional
there's a a moment uh aha moment he was
he had a fight in las vegas
and he was interviewed early in the
morning
by radio
and and also fighting in las vegas at
that time in a wrestling match was a guy
by the name of gorgeous george
and so they're both there early in the
morning and the interviewer turns to
muhammad first cassius clay at this time
says cassius how are you going to do in
the fight kasha says i'm going to win
the fight i'm very confident i've
trained i'm in shape
my opponent's good it's going to be a
good fight i encourage everybody to come
out and watch a fight that's going to be
a good fight but i'm going to win
then he turns to gorgeous george and he
says george gorgeous
whatever you call him
how are you gonna do it i'm gonna murder
him i'm gonna rip off his arm i'm gonna
tear out his if if i lose i will crawl
across the ring on my knees i will kiss
his feet i will ask for forgiveness and
cassius what
wow
i'd like to see that fight okay
so it suddenly was born the louisville
limp that's another cass's clay and then
we have other
so so i forgot the original question he
realized that that was a performance
that could enhance his career and so he
developed that performance
but in fact he was a young man
looking for knowledge oh
back to malcolm okay and that's what he
found that malcolm x was able to provide
and so it turns out
that this young man just listened very
carefully to everything malcolm x told
him he had never seen a man
so strong so proud
and so outspoken
he said after meeting malcolm for the
first time he said how can a black man
say that and not get shot okay he
couldn't understand it that that this
guy could would speak his mind in such a
forceful manner
and that strength
appealed to him i think
that strength appealed to him
the religion appealed to him
elijah muhammad appealed to him but his
relationship with malcolm was so close
and you're going to have to read the
book to find out a lot of the details of
all of these fights but
at the most crucial fight in his life
the heavyweight championship fight
against sunny liston
is when the relationship with malcolm
became closer than ever
why
cassius clay
in in february of 1964
was fighting the most
fearsome
man in christendom
or beyond christendom
sunny liston sunny liston was joe lewis
mike tyson and every
tough fighter you can imagine an ex-con
just tough
he had won his two previous he'd won the
title on his first defense both with one
round knockouts
it was assumed
he was going to end cash's clay's career
i interviewed his life if not his wife i
interviewed one reporter that for the
fight a robert lip site and bob told me
he said look when i was sent down there
as a young reporter for the new york
times to cover the fight
his seniors at the time said okay here's
what we want you to do kid
you're going to cover the fight because
they're not going to send a top-notch
reporter because it's only going to last
a few seconds so they said let's say
look you go down here's what i want you
to do when you get down there number one
find the fastest way from the arena to
the nearest hospital okay because we
want you to get there first to be able
to interview cassius clay or to when
they pronounce him dead you know to
report on this and so he goes down he
doesn't so
everybody thinks that every reporter
thinks he's going to lose everybody
feels that he's afraid of listening that
this that this kid will not last
but malcolm
gave him strength
malcolm said
look
allah has not brought you to this point
for you to lose
this is ordained you are part of allah's
plan for america for the world you are
going to win this is a battle between
the crescent and the cross and before
he came to now malcolm came to the
dressing room and they got down and they
prayed together and of course
if you've ever been in the bowels of a
big auditorium and tried to find out
where exactly is east okay if you want
to pray
with
straw way is east right they did the
best they could um and but it's it was
and malcolm said this is the crescent
and the cross what is crucial also you
find out in this book
is that this was the time as you pointed
out that
malcolm and elijah muhammad were
drifting apart
and
until i read this book i didn't know
that not even
elijah muhammad
and his sons in chicago
really believed
that cassius clay would win this fight
malcolm it would appear was the only
person
who
in the nation of islam
believed that he was going to win oh i'm
certain that's true
i'm
cassius i think maybe had an inkling
that he could win he had a plan for
winning but as mike tyson once said you
know everybody has a plan until they get
hit in the face
then plans go out the window you know
it's odd being what's being optional my
nose is bleeding um
but yeah he he had a belief
but
by this time
malcolm has been silenced by the nation
he's once
well he's silenced because remember
we're talking november i mean november
22nd right kennedy was assassinated and
we're talking about a flight that is now
february 25th so we're just a few months
away from that
america is just coming out of its
morning one of the great stories also it
talks about kind of a pivot
in our culture at that time
but muhammad was interviewed was
introduced to uh
four white
brits
that he had never really heard of uh
that hardly
they were the beatles okay so you know
here we have the beatles
and and
still cassius clay
dealing with each other before the fight
it's almost you know you can foresee the
direction of
the of our american population
two of them were the most to most
important
cultural phenomena of the 1960s the
beatles and who was then cassius clay
wow
that's my opinion but i don't think
anybody's going to you know you're not
going to convince me they weren't the
two most important
well at this point
malcolm and elijah muhammad are having
their differences
why
not only because malcolm wanted to
become more politically active
but because he had he was becoming
disillusioned
with elijah muhammad at the time
and elijah muhammad having suspended him
was livid at him but when
cassius clay
wins the fight
these two men are very close together
what pulls them apart
what pulls
cash is in malcolm yes
now suddenly the nation of islam
is embracing him
brother we knew you were going to win
that fight okay
we we know we didn't say anything we
didn't want to jinx it but we knew it
all along that you were going to win the
fight
malcolm is going another direction
elijah muhammad
doesn't care about malcolm leaving okay
that's a foregone conclusion but he
wants cassius clay in the organization
now cassius clay imagine you've been
mentored by a man
who when he says anything to you
begins it with the phrase the honorable
elijah muhammad teaches
okay the elijah the honorable elijah
muhammad says the the source of all
wisdom the source of all power
of malcolm's power of ali's
power comes from elijah muhammad but now
malcolm says you know
the honorable elijah muhammad is a
hypocrite okay he's not practicing what
he's preaching he's doing all these
things wrong
what does claisen think
have you been lying to me all these
years you know
i'm not sure i believe that okay
also
malcolm is venturing out into very
dangerous territory
because if you leave the nation of islam
at that time
bad things could happen to you okay and
and and and members of the nation are
saying to cassius look
malcolm will get what's coming to him
the chickens will come home to roost
again
and so what's he going to do he really
plays it safe he he stays with and then
finally elijah muhammad gives him his
name malcolm wanted him to have another
name
his first name was was cash's x correct
and the x stood for
the nation believed that
your slave your last name was your slave
name the black's last name so what you
did is you got rid of your last name and
you used x x symbolized your lost
african culture and that's why you had
malcolm x and
leon x and
louis farrakhan at that time with louis
louis x exactly
but
when elijah muhammad gave him the name
muhammad ali
psychologically i guess
malcolm knew he had lost him didn't he
malcolm was listening
to the sermon when the name was given to
him he was in a car
and when he heard it malcolm said that's
political that's for any you know he
realized he had lost
and
once he had lost him and
he had also lost
the nation of islam their
paths
veered away from one another
and he tried and tried
to see muhammad ali and couldn't see him
and then after he broke from the nation
of islam
he went to africa
to god he had become more international
in his outlook
what happened in ghana
the last time
that muhammad ali and malcolm x saw each
other was in ghana was in accra ghana
outside of the ambassador hotel it was
totally by a coincidence
malcolm was leaving cassius was arriving
and i might say in africa is when ali
starts to think of himself as the king
of the world worried
but
malcolm
as he throughout his visit
in africa people sometimes confuse them
with muhammad ali and would come up to
him and say no no that i'm not
i i'm not muhammad and he brought a
picture of him and muhammad he said this
is this is muhammad ali the heavyweight
champion this is my friend my very good
friend so malcolm still loved ali still
cared about him still considered him
friends and when he saw muhammad ali he
started to say
muhammad brother muhammad and he started
going to him and ali looked at him i
mean looked
dead in his eyes just
darts coming out and said you shouldn't
have said that about the honor of elijah
muhammad and turns around
and walks away
and maya angelou was with was with
malcolm she was driving him in her
little fear she was and and
and she said that the malcolm said you
know
i've lost a lot maybe too much i mean it
just it broke them it almost broke them
and
we all know what happened after that
ultimately with malcolm x but
in the case of muhammad ali he stayed in
the nation of islam for another maybe
decade or so yeah 1975 after elijah
muhammad dies he follows wallace
mohammed who moves the nation into a
more
orthodox islamic direction
and so he becomes a more orthodox muslim
right a couple of things about the book
first the title why is it called blood
brothers
several people said they were like
brothers
okay and and that's certainly part of it
one person even said they were like
blood brothers but beyond that
we're dealing with
blood
as a leak motif throughout this book i
mean boxing is a sport of blood politics
at this time was a sport of blood this
is a time of assassination this is a
violent time for america and uh uh we're
trying to get that sense of the violence
of america and and yet how do you
maintain a relationship between two
powerful people
during that time
we are almost about the point where
we're going to take questions from these
so if you have a question simply raise
your hands and we will come to you the
other thing that fascinated me about the
book is the cover
i have never seen
malcolm x look this playful
before
he's
looking down at muhammad ali with a
camera in his left hand he has his
hand on muhammad ali's shoulder muhammad
ali is looking over his shoulder
as if he's trying to figure out
is this the same serious
leader that i've known
so far why is he being looking so
playful
because they were playing with each
other uh at that time they were they
were celebrating that was taken the
night right after
cassius clay won the heavyweight
championship of the world
and instead of going to the fountain
blue hotel
big famous
hotel in miami
they went back where they were supposed
to be a big celebration for clay the
problem with the celebrations nobody
really had planned one because everybody
thought he was going to lose so they had
to kind of throw it together at the last
second um but that's where his his white
sponsoring louisville sponsoring group
went but he went and malcolm went back
to the hampton house
a black hotel in the black section of
miami and and they were
playing around and joking and you know
smiling at each other and mugging and
and and mountain was taking pictures
all along this thing but the interesting
thing is they go then get serious and
they go up to malcolm's room
and they're talking and they're also in
the room was jimmy jimmy brown jim brown
the great football player and
sam cook was there too the great singer
a change is going to come
change is going to come and and
at one point malcolm leaves the room
and cassius says to jimmy brown says you
know
i maybe leave you know this might be it
for
the the last dance for me in malcolm
okay
we may be forced apart
he didn't confine that to malcolm he
confronted it the journey down and we
all know ultimately that
malcolm was assassinated but
by
1996 when muhammad ali
at the olympics in atlanta was carrying
the torch for the united states
he had become the most beloved athlete
in the united states
from a period
when people were rooting for sonny
liston
against him
because of his religious beliefs his
religious beliefs never changed he's
still a muslim to this day what changed
that caused muhammad ali to become so
beloved
he took controversial stand several
things but one is he took a
controversial stand on vietnam which was
incredibly unpopular when he took it
1966 or so but by the time after a few
years it became mainstream so he was
seen as kind of a martyr for the
anti-war cause
also
he became debilitated okay he lost that
sharp verbal gift he lost that
power
that he once had
and
maybe a third thing is it might be it
may say something about the power of
american popular culture to absorb
dissidents uh you know we've we've made
wallpaper out of the you know
eldridge cleaver and the black one and
the uh black panthers so
we were able to absorb
all right if you have any questions now
is the time to raise your hand yes you
sir
uh first of all thank you both um i'm a
big fan of yours jojo
thank you mr rob for being here
i know when you approach a project where
you're writing something historical
there's a lot of research and it's an
investigative process and you probably
had some perspectives before
um you started writing this as you went
through the process and then at the
conclusion of it did you have any
perspectives that you felt were changed
by the process of actually going through
about either
were you changed during the course of
writing this book was
your point of view on anything altered
as a result of the process of writing
this book
well first of all
i we wrote acknowledgements
for the book all the people that have
helped us writing the book and the
research
and and i realize now that there was one
person i didn't thank
and that was j edgar hoover
because
without jag or hoover's obsession with
investigating every black man in america
that expressed a controversial opinion
uh we i wouldn't have had all these
wonderfully uh redacted documents to
look at uh because whatever anything
that was taking place in the nation of
islam
there could be four people four leaders
in the room
talking about important decisions
and one of them was working for the fbi
i have my guesses on which one it was
but i won't go into that
but
what surprised me is i thought
i knew
who muhammad ali was
and he turned out to be a much more
mercurial
person than i ever expected that that
you know somebody one person
interviewed talked about it he's
figuring out muhammad ali is like
figuring out a part or game okay
there's just so many different facets of
this personality and he to me was
endlessly interesting
anyone else
question just raise your hand here's
another
uh you would mention that uh muhammad
ali khan was had a separation
before he came to the nation
so when
when uh wd muhammad switched to uh
to more orthodox islam that would
embrace uh white people dozens too was
that
how what was that typical transition for
muhammad ali and like most of his
relationship with fairclough
at all attempted to join lewis americans
being constituted nation islam
you mentioned that muhammad ali had
separatist views before he joined the
nation of islam
so when
elijah muhammad's son
wallace d muhammad
decided to take the nation
in a
direction of orthodox islam
why did muhammad ali choose to go with
him
as opposed to going with louis farrakhan
i don't think he he had any problems
going that direction uh
in many ways he had always lived in an
integrated world
uh his first sponsoring group were white
his manager i mean his trainer uh angelo
dundee throughout his career was white
he had many white friends
um
and so i i think he was actually more
comfortable and in some ways he he was
moving the direction that malcolm had
started to move when malcolm was
assassinated so no i there was never any
reservations that i that i was able to
ascertain
but he talked about the process of
writing this book this is as far as i
know the first book that you have had a
co-author on
um how was that process for you working
with the co-op actually i've worked on a
co-author with several books in my bed
it's okay
though
you probably have heard me give
interviews before i usually take all the
credit
no
i
love
if it's the right co-author it's a
little bit like a marriage okay if it's
a right wife it really works out well if
it's not the right wife okay it doesn't
work out as well um
no i like it because when you're writing
a book it's an intensely solitary
thing
and you know even your family they
pretend like they're sort of interested
in what you're doing
but they're really not okay you know
they may be able to take a minute or two
uh you know it's it's like talking about
you know listening to other people talk
about their children you know
give me give me the brief version
um
but when you have a co-author
you're both interested in it okay you go
and research
when you go on a research trip they can
be really kind of boring i mean you
spend your time all day long in the
archive then you're sort of alone at
night but when you're going with
somebody else you're talking about it
you're working through problems together
and that my co-author johnny smith was
just
a fabulous co-author and and you know we
we we learned to complete each other's
sentences you know trying to figure it
out trying to piece this puzzle together
so i recommend co-authors i think it's
great
how long did the process take for you
when did you
first conceive
after thinking about a book about
muhammad ali then deciding that it was
going to be a book about the
relationship between him and malcolm x
how long after that did it take for you
to get it all together
i would say
probably
from the time we really started hard
work because
academics
spend a lot of time just thinking about
not doing anything okay you know
drinking coffee i don't drink coffee but
i should drink coffee but you know
but once every maybe about two and a
half years
from the time maybe three years from the
time we really started to do hardcore
research until the book was finished
any other questions here you sir
um
i think what i'm from the caribbean and
i grew up at a time when um especially
my father generation and stuff like that
those are the people who got me
interested in ali
i i remember that you know when he lost
his fight against you're describing my
generation
yeah you might be a little bit older
than me but we are so so close we the
same generation but
um i remember when you lost the fight
there um they take me to
see when he lost a fight against joe
lewis right these are men who are not
emotional people and practically you
could hear people crying but
that
so my
my relationship with him goes back a
long time i like to believe that but
there are three interesting things that
you see seem to me to be talking about
here and one of them
is the issue of who is muhammad ali
right
he's a very very
he's basically kind of i don't want to
overdo this now but he's basically like
jesus christ right he can
mix and match to all type of changes in
the society right
if you come inside oh that's value well
yes but uh you know
how do you think
in that multi-dimensional
flexible
uh
situation that he identity wise facing
right at a time when african americans
are massively protesting in the civil
rights movement right
um
you know demanding you know change etc
women are demanding change uh you know
um you have the beginning of the vietnam
war right what is interesting you didn't
touch on it is the fact that
uh
um
um
uh who i'm talking about um
the other black leader other important
black leader instead of malcolm x
right vietnam vietnam speech right
well ali ali reflects the vietnam speech
very quickly right right
i'm not doing this no vietnamese killed
me no yes misha i'm not going right
but all of this was was tremendously
controversial so how do you see
all of these changes right
reflect into this kind of a character
who himself is kind of trying to figure
out where he stands against all of these
multi-layer changes taking place and
maybe then they can the complexity that
try to define who he is at ultimate uh
muhammad ali was a multifaceted complex
man living in
multifaceted complex times
how did he negotiate his way
through those times
i'm not sure
they spent a lot of time
thinking about it
okay he just
moved forward okay
you know and he he took every hurdle as
it came
he he's he's he's in in some ways was a
a paradoxical person he's a person that
you know kind of represents today kind
of peace and love and fellowship and
brotherhood
but you know i know people that have
talked to him and
said you know he
he he was a wonderful person to be
around but he was never would never
really ask questions about somebody else
okay i mean you know he he he just kept
moving forward and
it's it's it's almost as if he picked up
reflections from the society and and we
created the partially created the
muhammad ali that we wanted to believe
was there
uh i don't think he was working on it
that much but he took a major
financial hit
by refusing the draft he lost
his career for many many years what gave
him the strength and the fortitude to
withstand that several things number one
i don't think money mattered to him at
all
okay i you know he wasn't in anything
for money
you know michael jordan
when he was asked to be involved in a
controversial political campaign you
know he said hey
republicans buy nikes too okay he didn't
want to do it
muhammad ali refused to be fenced in
money wasn't important to him therefore
after winning the heavyweight
championship the next day he gave a
famous to me a declaration of
independence speech where he says look
i don't have to be who you want me to be
i'm free to be who i want to be
you know
to me that resonates with we just went
through the super bowl and beyonce and
everybody's criticizing oh well why did
she sing that song why didn't she sing
uh you know put a ring on the finger or
something like that you're right you
know
that's what beyonce okay
it's pretty weak it's a pretty good
impression but
you know it's you know to me this is
great to see that you know that
that she's saying hey i'm i you pick me
for the super bowl okay you want me for
your agenda fine i'm going to use it for
my agenda okay and if it costs me an
endorsement okay i'm only worth
a billion five instead of a billion six
so okay
i can live with it
you're not gonna be who you want me to
be you have follow oh here's this young
lady
totally separate going back to when you
were
starting to write the book he said
originally you were going to write a
book about
were you going to
and this is an unusual where you start a
book and at first you see it this way
and then you know by the time you you
realize no this is the book that i want
to write that's how that's not that
unusual it's happened a few times to me
but you were writing about a period
during which as you pointed out
there was a great deal of conflict
assassinations were taking place there
was a lot of violence and in the
relationship the deteriorating
relationship
between malcolm x and the nation of
islam it was a very scary time so i'm
wondering in writing the book the people
you talk to
about that period were there still
people who were reluctant to talk to you
about what went on during that period or
has enough time passed so that people
were willing to be frank and open
about everything that happened because a
lot happened most of the people that
were in any position to know what was
going on
are gone are gone
but for example captain sam
still around we talked with captain sam
and he was a wonderful interview and
he would still hold pretty hard views
towards malcolm i think would be safe to
say i mean it's uh it
time hasn't softened all the edges
in this case did you attempt to
interview um minister louis farrakhan at
all uh you we we attempted but we were
unsuccessful
yes the book does point out that in very
many ways
louis x's he was then called
was chosen by elijah muhammad in many
ways to replace malcolm x correct well
and but the main replacement in terms of
as a recruiting and that they used all
the time in that mohammed speaks for a
newspaper was
muhammad ali himself
you had a follow-up oh you had to follow
go ahead
what were uh
what were muhammad ali's experiences
with christianity growing up and did
that influence his decision to become a
member nation
he had a typical
southern black experience with
christianity his mother was a good
baptist i you know he went to church
no i don't think it did i think probably
his father influenced it uh and his
experience influenced the separatism
and and that's what he really liked
about is this idea of separatism but
his
you couldn't have told it from his
upbringing pretty traditional
yes sir
um
talk about did you use the foyer laws to
get in the origin
did you use foyer blows to get any of
your information
uh some but most of the information most
of the
main files we looked at had already been
declassified for example you know elijah
muhammad's file malcolm x's file some of
the other lieutenants files
and also police files in new york so
most of them have already been
declassified and most a lot of them you
can get online the hard thing about
using those is that they're so redacted
that unless
we really had a we knew where the two
characters were day by day
and that helped us to see when they were
close to each other and it helped us
kind of provide a key to decipher what
the documents were saying because if you
look at an fbi document as you know
the dac did that you know five words the
doctor that
but we were able to get a a great deal
out of them
johnny was a master at it we only have
time for one more question my caribbean
brother tried to make it three
two questions um
make them make them both brief then
uh the first one is um
obviously mohammed was stopped fighting
at the very top point of his career i
mean you in many ways he lost the very
best years of inaudible career that was
going to be even more magnificent than
it ended up being that's the first thing
the second thing obviously being stopped
by a white power structure at that time
who he was who he was challenging visa v
vietnam
did you see that play out in a way for
example in um towards uh how african
americans saw him how the black panthers
saw him et cetera et cetera do you see
that as radicalizing in a certain way
the um civil rights movement and black
people towards the white power structure
at that point in time you didn't see
that did you see muhammad ali's actions
having
a radicalizing effect
on the black power structure i guess the
civil rights movement i don't know about
radicalizing it was radicalized i i see
him as becoming he became the patron
saint
of
liberal
leftist causes there was a one great
image and it was in a cover of esquire
magazine where they showed him and his
boxing gear
stretched out with arrows thrown
obviously at takeoff from the famous
painting of saint sebastian uh but you
know he was a martyr for the cause yes
and i'm afraid um that's going to have
to about wrap it up what's your next
book jeb bush marco rubio
i'm a trump man what could i say
no
something should be done i mean we talk
about celebrity yeah you know and now
celebrities taking over politics uh
so so we'll see we'll see it's gonna be
a boxing match all right
um a few words about wmu as we wrap up
and randy gets ready to sign your books
for those who are not familiar we are
the npr news station wmu is in the
district of columbia but more
importantly we are your public radio
station in this region you can find us
anytime at 885 on your fm radio dial or
at wamu.org via the npr one app on your
smartphone and if anyone is interested
in talking about the station or radio
generally there are quite a few wamu
colleagues here in the audience they're
usually the ones with wine glasses
sarah cumbie
[Laughter]
and if you work at wmu please raise your
hand
we'd be happy to chat
and again thank you all for coming out
tonight
i had a good time i would have paid for
this
[Applause]
thank you mandy thank you kojo thank you
all so so much for coming if you could
do us a favor help us by folding up your
chair placing against the bookcase on
the far wall please do come up say hello
get a book and have it signed thanks
everybody
okay
when i tune into it on the weekends
usually it's authors sharing their new
releases
watch